uh hi there steve kaufman here um
i
got through my um
presentation for the conference in
moscow
um
if i can figure out how i will try to
make a video
in russian and also in other languages
based on the slide presentation that i
developed for this conference in moscow
i was able to watch some of the other
presenters
including our good friends luca and
richard who were
actually in moscow making presentations
luca was talking uh more generally about
language learning and richard was
talking about how to bring up
multilingual children
both presentations were very interesting
um
you know i didn't sit through all of it
because it was breakfast time here
um i did see more of luca's presentation
that i did of richards
um
and a lot of what luca says i i
thoroughly agree with
uh in terms of you know
finding your own path doing the things
that you like to do
focusing on interesting content staying
motivated all of the sort of um
aspects of attitude that are so
important and uh making use of of dead
time and the advantage of modern
technology and so forth and so on of
course there are areas where uh luca and
i differ or richard and i differ or luca
and richard differ and but but
in essence we don't differ because we
all agree that uh each person has to
find their own path and has to do things
that that they find enjoyable
one of the things that
luca
said
was he was pointing out you know or are
asking whether or not we can learn the
way children learn and i think he sort
of implied that we can
and that um
that the the children have so many
advantages over us in that they are they
have more exposure to the language
um they aren't inhibited they're not
afraid to make mistakes
um
and so forth and that they are corrected
all the time and everything that luca
said i agree with except for one thing
i don't believe children are corrected
all the time
uh and that's something that i hear
always
that
you know children are constantly
corrected by their mother or by their
parents and that's why they speak their
native language so well i don't believe
that i do believe and i do agree with
luca that essentially the way we learn
our second language is the same process
as the way we learn our first language
in other words we learn from exposure to
the language the brain starts to sort
out how this language works
there are differences of course
and some of the differences luca pointed
out for example
and i'll go to my own experience i was
born in sweden for the first five years
of my life i only heard swedish
not only because my parents also spoke
german at home
but i have no recollection of that but i
do know that i arrived in canada at the
age of five
only speaking swedish
i have no recollection
of moving from a person
being a person who only spoke swedish to
a person who only spoke english because
within a year or two i could no longer
speak swedish and i just spoke english
as if it was natural
i learned my english
at school i learned it from my peers
i doubt if my mother
ever she might have corrected me how
much can she correct
basically we pick up language from
exposure
um i don't believe
that children let's say in canada or the
u.s
whose parents are not native speakers of
english will necessarily be poorer
speakers of english because they'll pick
it up in the schoolyard they'll pick it
up
at school and it won't be because
they're corrected if anything we are
corrected more often when we learn our
second language at school we're
constantly corrected and we end up
unable to speak that language
the difference is the amount of exposure
and that's where i entirely agree with
luca
we get so much exposure in our first
language
some might be from our parents some from
our peers
uh but it's not that we're corrected
it's that we get so much more exposure
uh now if we look at the differences
between
adults and children of course
children and i can think of my own
example i was only interested in
communicating i was not interested in
being corrected i was not interested in
i was not concerned about how i sounded
i didn't notice if i made mistakes i
gradually picked up on how things were
supposed to be said
so that the children the biggest
advantage
from the point of view of an attitude
the biggest advantage they have is
they're not worried about how they sound
they only want to communicate so if we
as adults
were able to have a similar attitude to
just focus on communication and not
worry about how we sound we would do a
lot better and we would probably become
more attuned to how the language is used
and naturally pick it up so that's one
difference the children are only
interested in communicating
they get a lot more exposure they're
only interested in communicating but the
process is the same now obviously adults
have certain advantages no i should say
before we move to advantages adults have
another disadvantage and that is that
their brain has already kind of
coalesced around
one language so this now is sort of
interference insofar as learning a
second language but that needn't be a
big obstacle as was the case with my
moving from swedish to english if we get
enough exposure
however if we allow our first language
to influence us
then
it will and i'll use the example of my
father my father spoke english very well
lived in canada for 40 years
uh
30 years actually until he passed away
and he was forever influenced by
the way he felt
english should be pronounced
as an example there's a province in
canada called nova scotia
s-c-o-t-i-a nova scotia that's how it's
said in english to him it was always
nova
scotia to him he felt it should be nova
scotia because if he were at all
interested in pronouncing it the way
native speakers pronounced it he would
have said nova scotia and we see this
all the time that we are influenced by
how words are pronounced in our own
language and i've used this example that
a spanish speaker might say ward or
guard instead of word
and and kind of refuses to notice that
word bird heard uh third that all that
the o and the i and the e a vowel sound
are all pronounced the same so if we are
if we want to improve our pronunciation
if we pay attention to what we're
listening to if we get enough exposure
we can actually get quite close to
native-like pronunciation but very often
in the case of the adult there is that
interference from
his or her native language
uh the other thing is
if we now talk advantages of course that
the adult has a much larger vocabulary
in his or her native language has a
broader life experience and therefore
can learn
a lot of vocabulary and can can become
capable of expressing quite um you know
sophisticated or complicated concepts in
a new language faster than
a child
and i'll use my again my own example you
know within a year of learning check i
can read books on history i can
understand political interviews i don't
think a four-year-old
child after one year of czech would
so those are some of the differences but
the the actual process of learning i'm
quite convinced
uh is very similar now again with regard
to grammar an adult may spend more time
reading some grammar rules and and i i'm
not an extreme crashonite i think that
reading grammar rules and studying
grammar tables
does help to some extent
it helps us notice things in the
language just as being corrected which
krashen has demonstrated in in in
numerous research articles has very
little effect and i'm sure that that's
correct but in my experience it has some
effect it's part of those little things
that help us notice
massive exposure helps us notice because
again the first time through you don't
notice a thing and by
repeatedly listening and reading you
start to notice more and more so
i still believe that the essential
process of learning
is the same
in other words it's it's largely through
exposure massive exposure exposure to
things of interest
and that willingness to engage in
meaningful communication
and and if if we as adults had as much
exposure as the child
has and had the same attitude of of not
worrying about how we sound then i think
probably adults can learn uh
maybe not quite as well when it comes to
pronunciation because our minds our
brains are more
uh
sort of rigidly
uh
sort of predetermined now
to process the native language whereas
the child is more flexible in that
regard but we can learn
by and large somewhat different to
different degrees we can be as
successful better on the vocabulary side
maybe less
capable on the pronunciation side but
adults can learn as well but i do
believe that essentially essentially the
process is the same
so and if i can figure out how i can
make an imovie out of my uh powerpoint
or in fact keynote presentation
i will do so uh first in russian and
then in other languages so thank you for
listening bye for now